Here we have an incline plane with a person pushing this, let's say rock,
100 kg up the plane, trying to get it to a height of 1 m.
We saw in the last unit that to analyze a block in an incline plane instead of writing mg
like normally do going straight down, we can break it into components,
which we call perpendicular and parallel components.
For the case of a nice smooth frictionless plane, this parallel force is balanced by the pushing force
of the guy who I just erased, sorry guy
and the perpendicular force is balanced by the normal force
of the surface of this plane pushing up against the block.
We show in the problem set that the perpendicular force can be expressed
as the weight times the cosine of this angle, which we have called α
and the parallel force here can be expressed as this mgsin α.
Can you tell me for the case of a 100 kg block and angle of 30°, what would this parallel
force of gravity, the force tending to pull the block down the incline plane.
What would that be equal to?